vlada empezado una nueva vida llegó hace
dos meses a chisinau donde ha encontrado
un trabajo temporal en un polígono
industrial ha dejado atrás familia y sus
sueños de futuro forma parte de los
jóvenes que no quieren combatir en la de
arrancar nuestro ego en este año iba a
acabar la universidad y quería montar mi
propio negocio de bicicletas llegó una
carta a casa de mis padres pidiendo que
acudiera a una oficina de registro
militar decidí huir a moldavia
con lo que cobra la edad para pagar una
pequeña habitación en un apartamento
compartido nos sale mucho de casa le
pese a su decisión de haber ido pero el
que asiste apoya al bando ruso en la
guerra y se escala tendrá que luchar
contra el cráneo
su abuelo luchó con el ejército
soviético contra los nazis en la segunda
guerra mundial ahora es diferente
por orden de rusia el gobierno nos está
diciendo que tenemos que prepararnos que
el otro lado de la frontera hay un
régimen nazi que quiere desestabilizar
la región están metiendo miedo a la
gente todo es mentira
andrew haya dejado todas sus cosas en su
piso de estudiante de moscú pero se ha
traído su mesa de mezclas no podría
vivir sin sus sesiones de música
experimental llegó hace unos días y se
está quedando en casa de unos amigos en
chisinau
no podía estar más tiempo en moscú la
situación es insoportable cada día se
ven más pintadas en los muros la letra
zeta que significa apoyo a la guerra hay
una fuerte presencia policial en las
calles ya ni siquiera podemos usar las
redes vpn seguras para navegar en
internet no hay libertad de opinión y
han aumentado las redadas a activistas
andrew no puede visitar a su familia en
tiráspol porque el ejército de
transnistria lo está buscando para que
se enrolen el servicio mental
andray blatche pertenecen a una minoría
silenciada rusa sus testimonios sirven
para dar luz y no estigmatizar a una
población a la que no se ha preguntado
si quiere la guerra